kirti borah has been bedridden since the
police shot him in the leg last month
they say he's a drug peddler and
attacked them first but borah says he
was just in the wrong place at the wrong
time pharmacist medicine
i was coming from the pharmacy when i
saw some people beating up a man it's
all because of that they first abused me
and then shocked me i'm totally innocent
after taking office last may the chief
minister of assam in india's north east
has adopted a zero tolerance policy
against crime and burned piles of drugs
to promote the campaign
now his government is facing allegations
of human rights violations after 28
people were killed and more than 70
injured in a series of shootings
involving police
authorities say officers have acted
lawfully when a criminal tried to
tries to flee or escape from the police
custody by taking away the
service revolver then definitely police
have to defend themselves and there may
be some incident of conflict and
contrast only because of that of self
defense and
all these things that they are doing uh
within the boundary of law
but members of journal abedin's family
says he was unarmed when the police
entered their home the police say he was
a gangster the family says he was framed
they asked him what he did he told him
he was a daily wage earner didn't do any
business then they put handcuffs kicked
him and dragged him to the courtyard
they took him and i kept asking where
are you taking him then we heard two
rounds of gunshots
lawyer and rights activist rf jodhar has
petitioned the courts to order an
investigation into killings like these
and asked for compensation for the
families of those found to have been
wrongly killed it's not random there is
a pattern
we have seen according to my data
that most of the victims are from the
marginalized society
and by marginalized society i means
from the indigenous tribal people from
the minority muslims
and and from the poor people
in assam's high court state government
has denied any wrong doing
following public outrage over the
shooting of kirti borah one officer has
been suspended
he hopes he and others will get justice
but says some wounds may never heal pav
nimittal al-jazeera new delhi